us coach jurgen klinsmann shocked
American soccer fans when he dropped
legend Landon Donovan from the World Cup
roster he said other players were
outperforming Donovan klinsmann was
mildly criticized for the decision just
weeks before the world cup I believe
this meeting a heart attack of course
the media response shows that soccer in
the US now has a much higher standing
than it did eight or ten years ago when
I feel now there's a lot of talk about
our squad is cootie advert newborns
moncada the roster includes five
german-americans the highly experienced
jermaine jones and for young Bundesliga
players they insist that they do not
have a special role on the team steganos
team on shift I think the team as a
whole is good not because of the half
German players I think the team has good
rhythm stinking ass too much and that's
why we're currently performing well does
have also good function yet to two
distinct there we have a lot of
experienced players as well as younger
ones it's a good mix and we're looking
forward to the World Cup grab the phone
was overthrowing despite the high esteem
for the players with Bundesliga
experienced coach cleans mom doesn't
believe that the German influence
dominates became key topes national
squad is led by players from the US and
English leagues on Ken's leading man
they really play well together Kimmy
this chemistry and the spirit that the
Americans have in team sports are
amazing his own Darby and it'll
certainly play a major role for us in
advancing from this killer group to the
knockout phase open an inductive in
elevator to calm after Donovan's
exclusion many fans are pessimistic
about the team's chances
I feel like it's a mistake and I think
that we're going to find out in three
weeks what's going to happen
three-and-out I don't think they're
gonna make it through the group but
we'll hope for the best thank you for
many fans the US squad is no longer
america's team without donovan and
without some success in Brazil Jurgen
Klinsmann could face even more criticism